[Musik]
>> FREDERIC: Ich drücke wo drauf, während du anmoderierst.
Ich muss destruktiv wirken.
>> SALLY: Hallo! Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys
>> FREDERIC: Ah, Gott!
>> SALLY: Welt!
Ja, heute habe ich einen Gast hier.
Das ist der Freddie.
Den kennt ihr alle schon,
den Sturmi.
[Applaus]
Und wir müssen uns beeilen.
Denn die Kinder sind bald zurück.
Die Kinder, die sind schon seit Tagen aufgeregt,
weil der Sturmi zu Gast hier ist und zu Besuch.
Und ich bin echt ganz froh,
dass du nicht in den Ferien kommst.
Denn dann wären sie morgens schon um acht auf der Matte
und wollen mit dir zocken.
Ela will mit dir im Kinderzimmer spielen
und sie will
>> FREDERIC: Minecraft.
>> SALLY: rutschen und Minecraft zocken.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Machen wir noch.
>> SALLY: Und ja, das machen wir alles noch.
Ja.
Ich würde gern mit dir backen,
>> FREDERIC: Yes.
>> SALLY: weil du für mich mein großes Backvorbild bist.
>> FREDERIC: So einfach noch mal nehmen,
jetzt dreimal hintereinander schneiden
und einfach meinen Gesichtsausdruck daneben.
Das ist eine wahre Reaktion.
>> SALLY: Ach.
Und ich hätte mal eine Frage:
Isst du gerne Kuchen und Torten?
>> FREDERIC: Du, ja.
Das trifft sich, glaube ich, ganz gut heute.
>> SALLY: Ja?
Was ist denn deine Lieblings-klassische-Torte?
>> FREDERIC: Also...
>> SALLY: Gibt es so einen Klassiker, den du magst?
So richtig so Omarezepte? So
>> FREDERIC: Voll! Also ich würde...
>> SALLY: Frankfurter, Schwarzwälder...
>> FREDERIC: Ich würde...
Ja, genau.
Ich würde voll in so Schwarzwälder Kirsch reingrätschen.
Ist es eine Torte?
Man sagt Schwarzwälder Kirschtorte schon, nicht?
>> SALLY: Ja, Schwarzwälder Kirschtorte.
>> FREDERIC: Weil Schwarzwälder Kirschkuchen
hört sich blöd an.
>> SALLY: Nee. Für mich ist alles Torte
was mit Sahnecreme oder Buttercreme.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
Buttercreme war auch für mich,
als ich sie das erste Mal selber gemacht habe,
eine Enttäuschung.
>> SALLY: Aber ich muss zugeben, für mich auch damals.
>> FREDERIC: Oder?
>> SALLY: Ja. Ich war aber neun.
>> FREDERIC: Es ist wirklich so.
>> SALLY: Und du?
>> FREDERIC: Neun?
Neun.
29.
Nein.
Nein, aber es ist schon...
>> SALLY: Nein?
>> FREDERIC: Ja, aber...
>> SALLY: Die ist dir geronnen, gell?
>> FREDERIC: Nein.
>> SALLY: Nein?
>> FREDERIC: Nein, nein. Es war einfach nur...
Es war einfach nur
Butter und dann etwas Sahne oder so
und that's it.
>> SALLY: Und Pudding. Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, und Pudding oder so.
>> SALLY: Ach, dann, dass du realisiert hast,
dass da wirklich so viel Butter drin ist.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, ich dachte, das wäre eher so,
weißt du, wie das so oft ist, so eine gagige Phrase.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: So: Das ist Buttercreme.
Das hat halt die Konsistenz,
aber eigentlich ist es in Wirklichkeit so Salbei,
>> SALLY: Ja.
den du knetest, und dann irgendwie
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: aus Marokko irgendwie Liebe einfliegen lässt
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: und dann ist es so in dem Kuchen drin.
Aber nee,
>> SALLY: Ah,
>> FREDERIC: es ist einfach nur viel Butter.
>> SALLY: Josh, sag was zu unserem Butterkonsum.
>> JOSH: Er ist hoch, sehr hoch.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, ich verstehe das auch nicht,
wie ihr alle hier so ausseht.
Das ist echt so!
Woran liegt es?
Sport? Macht ihr das zusammen?
Einfach gute Laune?
>> SALLY: Gute Gene.
>> FREDERIC: Gute Gene?
>> JOSH: Gene, ja.
>> SALLY: Wir denken uns die Kalorien weg.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
Oder alle hier immer so bei der Arbeitszeit:
"Okay, wir können anfangen."
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, gut angucken.
>> SALLY: Also Schwarzwälder, ja?
>> FREDERIC: Yes.
>> SALLY: Sollen wir so richtig so basic?
Und ich hätte mir gedacht,
wir machen daraus einen Naked Cake.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und also so die klassische
Schwarzwälder Kirschtorte modernisieren
und ganz einfach machen, dass man bei der Deko
>> FREDERIC: Finde ich geil!
>> SALLY: wirklich nichts falsch machen kann.
>> FREDERIC: Geil!
>> SALLY: Oder?
>> FREDERIC: Ja, 400 Prozent bin ich dabei.
>> SALLY: Ja. Ich habe zufällig
ein paar Biskuitböden gebacken.
Sollen wir die nehmen
oder soll ich dir zeigen, wie man Biskuitböden backt?
>> FREDERIC: Lass mal die nehmen.
>> SALLY: Ja, sollen wir die nehmen?
Ich habe zufällig sogar einen Schokoboden.
>> FREDERIC: Wo kann man das denn sehen,
wie du die gemacht hast?
>> SALLY: Habe ich schon online, hoffe ich, zu dem Zeitpunkt.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
Ansonsten schneiden wir das raus.
Hallo! Herzlich willkommen zurück vom Cut!
>> SALLY: Ansonsten gibt es bald das Rezept.
Ich weiß noch nicht, wann ich was hochlade, deswegen.
>> FREDERIC: Echt?
>> SALLY: Einfach basic Biskuit.
Und wenn man sagt:
>> FREDERIC: Stimmt.
>> SALLY: "Hey, ich möchte kurz eine Torte mal backen,
aber ich habe nicht so viel Zeit",
man kann ja auch Biskuit kaufen.
Aber das fände ich ganz schlimm, weil
>> FREDERIC: Nee, der ist echt trocken immer auch.
>> SALLY: der ist immer ganz trocken
und vor allem sind es nur drei Zutaten:
Eier, Zucker, Mehl und das war es.
>> FREDERIC: Und bei mir noch eine vierte Zutat
und das ist eine Prise Glück.
>> SALLY: Und Vanilleextrakt.
Okay. Dann machen wir das.
Gut. Also Schwarzwälder Kirsch.
Machen wir die Kirschfüllung und die Sahne
und dann die Deko, ja?
>> FREDERIC: Yes.
>> SALLY: Okay. Ich hole mal eben Zutaten.
[Musik]
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: 70.
>> FREDERIC: 70.
Hm.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Nicht?
>> SALLY: Sehr gut!
Perfekt!
>> FREDERIC: Danke, Bernhard!
So.
>> SALLY: Okay. Also nehmen wir
Schattenmorellen.
Wir nehmen 40 Gramm Stärke.
>> FREDERIC: Warum heißen die Schattenmorellen?
>> SALLY: Ich weiß es nicht.
Warte. Ich google.
>> FREDERIC: Wirklich nicht?
>> SALLY: Mhm.
>> FREDERIC: Das würde mich voll interessieren.
Weil das ist für mich Kirschen in Wasser.
>> SALLY: Weil die im Schatten wachsen.
>> FREDERIC: Da habe ich letztens
ganz viel Ärger bekommen von Leuten.
>> SALLY: Ah!
>> FREDERIC: Weil ich habe das Kirschwasser
weggeschüttet und dann haben die gesagt:
"Machst du das sofort bitte mit Sprudel voll
und trinkst das Kirschwasser!"
Da habe ich gesagt: "Ich habe eine schwere Allergie."
Dann haben die gesagt: "Warum backst du dann damit?"
Da habe ich gesagt: "Stimmt. Ihr habt recht."
>> SALLY: "Die Schattenmorelle,
auch Große Lange Lotkirsche oder Nordkirsche,
ist eine Sorte der Sauerkirschen.
Sie gehört zur Familie der Rosengewächse
(Rosaceae)
und ist die am meisten angepflanzte Sauerkirschsorte.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Sie ist eine spätreife Sorte und bringt hohe Erträge.
Der Baum ist recht anspruchslos,
wächst auch im Schatten gut und trägt viele Früchte."
Jetzt wissen wir warum.
>> FREDERIC: Recht anspruchslos, im Schatten
>> SALLY: Anspruchslos.
>> FREDERIC: – mein Thema!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Jetzt wissen wir warum.
Weil die Sorte ertragreich ist und günstig ist.
Und wahrscheinlich...
>> FREDERIC: Mein Thema!
Wenn Baum, dann dieser jetzt.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Also für die Kirschfüllung, Schwarzwälder Kirsch,
>> FREDERIC: Drin lassen, nicht drin lassen?
>> SALLY: – nö, nicht drin lassen –
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: haben wir diese Zutaten.
Das Video wird etwas anders als sonst.
>> FREDERIC: Hey, was?
Du meinst, cooler?
>> SALLY: Viel cooler!
>> FREDERIC: Yes!
>> SALLY: Und spontaner.
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Also dann haben wir hier
40 Gramm Stärke,
70 Gramm Zucker,
ein Glas Schattenmorellen, weil sie im Schatten wachsen,
eine Prise Zitronenabrieb,
eine Prise Zimt
und etwas Vanilleextrakt.
>> FREDERIC: Ich habe übrigens noch ein Video offen bei mir.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> FREDERIC: Da wollte ich dein
Kühlschrank-richtig-einsortieren-Video nachstellen.
Weil ich habe keine Ahnung,
wo Sachen im Kühlschrank hinkommen.
>> SALLY: Ja!
>> FREDERIC: Die kommen einfach nur bei mir da rein,
weil da ist es ja kühl.
Ha!
>> SALLY: Ja, das musst du machen!
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: Das macht voll Spaß!
>> FREDERIC: Mh.
>> SALLY: Doch!
>> FREDERIC: Ja, ich sage mal immer,
der Radius, wo...
>> SALLY: Weiter mittig drücken.
>> FREDERIC: Der Radius, bei dem Spaß...
Es macht Spaß.
Ich halte meinen Mund.
>> SALLY: Ja.
[Musik]
Jetzt darfst du
Stärke, Zucker in den Topf geben.
>> FREDERIC: Einfach so?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Einfach rein?
>> SALLY: Einfach...
>> FREDERIC: Nicht anmachen?
>> SALLY: Nichts erst mal.
Erst mal noch gar nichts.
>> FREDERIC: Aber rein?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Nicht sieben?
>> SALLY: Mhm.
Das wird jetzt wie so eine Art Pudding gekocht.
>> FREDERIC: Schon wieder Pudding.
Ich habe durch dich schon sehr viel Pudding gemacht,
muss ich sagen.
Schon. Ist das ein Problem so mit Rührrechten?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Dann den Kirschsaft.
>> FREDERIC: Den Kirschsaft.
>> SALLY: Oh, wow! Ich hoffe, wir...
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
Kriege ich hin, sagst du, oder?
>> SALLY: Hm. Pass nur auf.
>> FREDERIC: Aha.
Ich gucke mal. Ich...
>> SALLY: Okay. Warte mal. Warte.
>> FREDERIC: Was denn? Ich kriege das hin!
>> SALLY: Ja? Schaffst du, oder?
>> FREDERIC: Ja, klar! Natürlich!
>> SALLY: Komm, das schaffst du.
>> FREDERIC: Ich muss einfach schnell schütten.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Das ist, glaube ich, das Thema.
Umso länger, umso unangenehmer.
Das tut mir auch leid.
>> SALLY: Wow!
Sehr gut!
Hm, hm, hm.
>> FREDERIC: Puh!
Mehr Druck als beim Abi gerade gehabt, ey!
Huiuiui!
>> SALLY: Sehr gut.
Yay!
>> FREDERIC: Puh!
Es fühlt sich an wie die Matheklausur
und am Ende war es doch nur eine 5+,
aber es hat gereicht.
>> SALLY: Sieht gut aus! Du schaffst das!
Und nicht das Weiße. Genau.
Okay. Stopp.
>> FREDERIC: Weil sonst ist es bitter beim Weißen, nicht?
Ich habe nämlich schön Nudeln mit Kaviar letztens gemacht
mit Zitronensoße.
War schön viel Weißes von der Zitrone.
War nämlich schön Zitrone-mit-bitter-Soße dann.
Ja, war toll!
Mmh, lecki!
>> SALLY: Mmh, lecker!
>> FREDERIC: War kein Leckobert.
So.
>> SALLY: Na toll!
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: Dann Vanille.
>> FREDERIC: Vanille oder Vanillie?
Jetzt bin ich mal hier. Jetzt kann ich fragen.
>> SALLY: Vanille?
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
Ja, ich weiß es ja nicht.
Das ist so eine große Debatte.
Ich dachte, du hättest da schon das Thema besiegelt.
>> SALLY: Vanilleextrakt.
>> FREDERIC: Vanilleextrakt.
Ein Schuss?
>> SALLY: Einen Schuss.
>> FREDERIC: Also ich mache immer ein bisschen mehr
als einen Teelöffel.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Weil dann ist es erst richtig geil.
>> SALLY: So der Ela-Move.
>> FREDERIC: Ja?
>> SALLY: Ja, ja. Ela ist auch so wow.
Ja, passt.
Und eine Prise Zimt.
>> FREDERIC: Ist das ein Prisenlöffel?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Lasst euch nicht stören.
Oder ist das jetzt gerade so...
Die Beziehung zwischen euch ist die so...
>> SALLY: Du stehst zwischen uns.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ich sage euch, ich mache euch beide fertig!
Eigentlich bin ich der YouTuber hier!
>> SALLY: Wir haben uns eigentlich...
Das ist eigentlich unser Blind Date hier.
>> MURAT: Aha. Okay.
>> SALLY: Wir haben uns auf parship.de gefunden.
>> MURAT: Freddie, das ist ein Monk.
>> FREDERIC: ElitePartner.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: ElitePartner.
>> MURAT: Freddie, das ist ein Monk.
Pass du auf, gell?
Pass bloß auf!
>> SALLY: Auf ElitePartner stand bei mir im Profil...
>> FREDERIC: Ich habe dich reinreden lassen ins Mikrofon.
>> MURAT: Ach so. Okay.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Die Technik dankt. Ja.
>> MURAT: Ah, hallo, hallo, hallo. Ich bin es, Murat.
>> FREDERIC: Du musst ein bisschen flüstern.
Weil dann haben wir noch
den unglaublichen ASMR-Aspekt drin.
>> MURAT: Krass! Was ist denn das?!
>> FREDERIC: Das ist ein Gerät, nicht?
>> SALLY: Ich probiere es aus.
>> FREDERIC: Oder?
>> MURAT: Hey Freddie, hier gibt es Sachen,
wo ich mich frage: Warum braucht man das?
Und dann braucht man es irgendwann mal.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, natürlich.
>> MURAT: Ja, das ist so im Leben.
>> SALLY: Weg da!
>> MURAT: Ja, ich gehe dann.
Ich bin im Garten.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Ich bin der Gärtner.
>> FREDERIC: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Der Gärtner war immer
entweder der Mörder oder die Affäre.
Ich lasse das so um Raum stehen.
Also so ein Teelöffel wäre schon jetzt ein halber Teelöffel.
Mach nur eine Prise.
So ganz wenig ganz wenig.
Weil das ist kein Prisenlöffel.
Ich habe den nicht gefunden.
>> FREDERIC: Ernsthaft?!
Da guckst du mal.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Prise kann ich aber inzwischen ganz gut.
>> SALLY: Noch weniger.
Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Piu!
Ein Schuss.
>> SALLY: Jetzt rühren.
Genau.
>> FREDERIC: Das ist ja noch nicht an jetzt, nicht?
>> SALLY: Nee.
Rühr du und dann können wir es anmachen.
So. Und dann können wir es auch aufkochen lassen.
Ich wusste nur nicht, wie lange du rührst.
Deswegen habe ich es noch nicht angemacht.
>> FREDERIC: Bringt das eigentlich was
mit dem Abziehen nach unten?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Achtung. Soll ich PowerBoost?
>> FREDERIC: Oh ja!
Juhu!
PowerBoost-Freddie!
Kriege ich einen eigenen Jingle?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Hallo, liebe Schnittabteilung,
ich hätte gern einen eigenen Jingle.
Ich singe euch das auch gerne ein.
Power Boost Freddy!
Immer mit Power!
Wer hat mal Aua?
Der Freddie!
Weil er ist verbrannt.
Aua, aua!
Power Boost Freddy!
Wer ist sauer?
Jetzt reicht es. Okay.
Ich sage es euch:
Wenn ihr mal einen Partner rankriegt,
die sagen: "Wir wollen nur Promo für PowerBoost machen
und Induktionsfelder",
>> SALLY: PowerBoost.
>> FREDERIC: dann ruft ihr mich sofort an!
>> SALLY: Ja, definitiv.
>> FREDERIC: Ich mache das Ding groß!
>> SALLY: Definitiv!
>> FREDERIC: Wasser hat noch nie so schnell gekocht,
nur mit mir.
>> SALLY: Auf 200°C!
>> FREDERIC: Auf 200°C.
Wollt ihr eure Nudeln mal nicht in elf Minuten al dente haben,
sondern in zwei?
PowerBoost!
>> SALLY: PowerBoost.
>> FREDERIC: Dann ist das okay so oder mehr?
>> SALLY: Das passt.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: So.
Oh, das sieht gut aus!
Das sieht gut aus!
Jetzt kannst du die noch mit reingeben.
>> FREDERIC: Yes!
Alle?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Einfach schütten?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Und dann unterheben?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Wie hebt man richtig unter?
Das müssen wir auch noch mal machen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Ich brauche Seminare hier.
>> SALLY: Aber ich will dir gar nicht so viel beibringen.
Weil ich finde, du machst das so schön
so, wie du das machst.
Das ist so wie bei der Ela, wenn sie so...
Weißt du? Wenn du so kleine Kinder hast
und die sprechen ein Wort falsch aus.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ela sagt zum Beispiel immer:
"Mama, mir ist so wangweilig!"
>> FREDERIC: Das sage ich auch immer!
>> SALLY: Wangweilig?
>> FREDERIC: Ich wusste doch, vier Jahre!
>> SALLY: Und dann will ich sie nicht korrigieren
und nicht sagen: "Ela, da ist ein L davor."
Weil "wangweilig" ist halt so süß.
>> FREDERIC: Ich hatte das immer damals
mit den Toten Hosen.
>> SALLY: Und dann lasse ich sie halt.
>> FREDERIC: Ich hatte einfach immer zu den Toten Hosen
– das konnte ich nicht aussprechen ganz lange früher.
Da habe ich immer "Die Woten Bosen"...
>> SALLY: Die Woten Bosen?
>> FREDERIC: "Die Woten Bosen"
ist mit eine meiner ersten Kindheitserinnerungen.
Das ist ein tragischer Moment gewesen,
hat viel
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: kaputtgemacht,
aber auch für viele Sachen den Weg geebnet, der Moment.
>> SALLY: Und dann sind das so Sachen,
die will man nicht korrigieren,
weil die einfach so süß sind.
>> FREDERIC: Ja. Also ich sage ja nach wie vor...
>> SALLY: Deswegen zeige ich dir auch nicht,
wie man Sahne steif schlägt.
>> FREDERIC: Nee, ich finde das gut, du.
Also ich habe schon mehrfach öffentlich
über meine Erziehungsmethoden gesprochen,
wenn ich später mal Kinder habe.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Und da sind schon so Sachen dabei.
Also ich glaube, ich werde mir schon viele Späßchen erlauben.
Das machst du schon alles richtig.
>> SALLY: Ja, nicht?
>> FREDERIC: Ich habe immer gesagt,
ich bringe meinen Kindern bei,
dass eine Zwiebel ein Apfel ist und ein Apfel eine Zwiebel,
und dass die dann irgendwann,
wenn sie in die Welt entlassen werden,
mit dieser Enttäuschung wiederkommen,
dass ich sie einfach sieben Jahre lang verarscht habe.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Und dann will ich einfach da nur sagen so:
"Das ist die Welt.
So funktioniert das hier alles.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Und das war nur Apfel/Zwiebel.
>> SALLY: Nimm die Zwiebel!
>> FREDERIC: Also sei vorsichtig!"
>> SALLY: Okay.
Willst du probieren?
>> FREDERIC: Voll gerne. Ja.
Boah!
>> SALLY: Aber jetzt weiß ich, dass die Creme
>> FREDERIC: Lecker!
>> SALLY: auch nicht so süß sein muss,
weil das hier auch schon süß genug ist, nicht?
>> FREDERIC: Voll!
Ja.
Total!
Aber lecker!
>> SALLY: Jetzt können wir das abkühlen lassen
ein bisschen kurz.
>> FREDERIC: Boah!
>> SALLY: So. Komponente eins war der Biskuit.
Den haben wir fertig.
Komponente zwei: die Füllung.
Und was fehlt noch?
>> FREDERIC: Die Sahne.
>> SALLY: Yeah!
Wir machen es einfacher.
Wir machen vielleicht Quark-Sahne.
>> FREDERIC: Cool! Ja, einfacher. Hm.
>> SALLY: Quark mit Sahne.
Quark mit Sahne ist einfacher.
Ich hole.
Ich hole die Zutaten.
So.
Dein Spezialgebiet! Du darfst die Zutaten vorstellen.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
Da fange ich natürlich total gerne mit an.
Wir haben hier zum einen Quark,
300 Gramm
>> SALLY: 500.
>> FREDERIC: – 500 Gramm,
Puderzucker, 50 Gramm,
Vanille made by Sally,
überall erhältlich, wo es Vanilleextrakt gibt,
Sahne,
versteckte Sachen.
>> SALLY: Dieses versteckte Pulver ist das hier,
>> FREDERIC: Ach so. Ja.
>> SALLY: dass man weiß was es ist.
San-apart zum Sahnesteifschlagen.
>> FREDERIC: Darf man sagen?
Sind wir cool mit...
>> SALLY: Ja, wir sind cool mit Küchle.
Die machen auch Esspapier. Kennst du das Esspapier?
>> FREDERIC: Boah! Was?!
>> SALLY: Dieses Knabber-Esspapier?
>> FREDERIC: Geil!
>> SALLY: Ja, das ist Küchle.
>> FREDERIC: Okay, wir sind richtig cool mit denen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Schickt mal was zu.
>> FREDERIC: Die schickt mir das dann.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Die haben so Zungentattoos.
>> FREDERIC: Das sind Leute, die so was sehen.
Jetzt bin ich
>> SALLY: Ja!
unter Druck. Bei mir ist immer so.
Keine Ahnung.
Das Beste, was bei mir passiert ist,
>> SALLY: Die schicken dir das.
>> FREDERIC: war einfach nur abends eine Nachricht so:
"Hi, ich bin es, Sido. Ich gucke deine Videos."
Das war das Beste, was mir jemals passiert ist.
Aber Küchle, wenn die Esspapier haben,
zehnmal geiler!
>> SALLY: Sogar Tattoo-Esspapier.
>> FREDERIC: Tattoo-Esspapier?!
>> SALLY: Da kannst du Zungentattoos machen so.
Hm.
Haben wir welche da?
>> FREDERIC: Auch mit Farbe?
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, wir haben keine da.
>> FREDERIC: Okay, wir sind sehr cool mit Küchle.
>> SALLY: Normalerweise haben wir immer welche da.
Mein Mixer hat übrigens keinen Namen
und er kriegt auch keinen.
>> FREDERIC: Warum nicht?
Du machst eigene Produkte.
>> SALLY: Weil ich die auspiepsen muss dann.
>> FREDERIC: Ich würde meine ganzen Produkte
immer so nennen.
Warum auspiepsen?
Ja, also ich würde den nicht so nennen wie meinen.
Der ist schon ein bisschen adult
– a- adult, adult.
Der ist ein bisschen adult.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Ja. Aber warum keine Namen?
Das ist doch viel cooler!
>> SALLY: Okay. Dann finde einen Namen für meinen Mixer.
>> FREDERIC: Sollen wir ihn vorher absprechen?
Nicht, dass du überrascht bist von dem Ergebnis.
>> SALLY: Nee, komm, schieß los.
>> FREDERIC: Ich würde den
[Trommelwirbel]
Rühri nennen.
>> SALLY: Rühri?
Oh, der Rühri!
Okay.
Gebongt.
Soll ich dir sagen wie?
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber, wenn du nach Hause gehst,
musst du es wieder vergessen.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ich finde es nämlich lustig,
wenn du Sahne schlägst.
Also Quark kommt hier rein.
>> FREDERIC: Du findest es lustig, wenn ich Sahne schlage?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Ich kann so gut Sahne schlagen inzwischen!
>> SALLY: Ich weiß.
>> FREDERIC: Ich habe so lange Becher.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Und dann gehen immer
meine komischen Stabmixer kaputt,
weil die immer sehr warm werden.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Und jetzt habe ich schon
den dritten Stabmixer in drei Monaten.
Das kann ich nicht gut.
>> SALLY: Ups.
>> FREDERIC: Aber es klappt.
Ich habe mal...
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, du hattest auch
mit deinem Stabmixer mit dem Schneebesen
Butter gerührt, die nicht so warm war.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, das kann sein.
Und da hat sich das hier so einmal komplett verdreht
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: und das sieht jetzt lustig aus.
>> SALLY: Das ist ja auch ein Schneebesen,
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: weil Schnee für Eischnee und Sahne.
>> FREDERIC: Ja. Oder wie ich ihn nenne, den Butterbesen.
Und der hat seinem Namen nicht alle Ehre gemacht,
würde ich sagen.
>> SALLY: Ojemine!
Ojemine!
Hm.
Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Ästhetisch ist anders, nicht?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Es tut mir sehr leid.
>> SALLY: Das ist okay.
>> FREDERIC: Das habe ich bei dir gesehen.
>> SALLY: Sieht gut aus.
>> FREDERIC: Du bist immer sehr
sehr schwäbisch.
Okay.
Was denn?!
>> SALLY: Oh, wow!
>> FREDERIC: Ein bisschen schwäbisch,
ein bisschen nachgekratzt, damit auch alles drin ist.
>> SALLY: Oh! Ich bin badisch!
>> FREDERIC: Ah, sorry!
Oje!
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> FREDERIC: Uff! Da wird es aber schwierig
mit der Schwarzwälder Kirschtorte.
>> SALLY: Puderzucker.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Hat er gerade geschwäbelt?
>> JOSH: Ha ja.
>> FREDERIC: Ich habe ein bisschen Schwäbisch geschwätzt.
>> SALLY: Ein wenig.
>> FREDERIC: Ein wenig.
Ein bisschen.
>> SALLY: Das habe ich mir fast gedacht.
>> FREDERIC: Alle sagen immer:
"Das hier ist badeutsich", sagen alle immer.
Ha ja.
>> SALLY: Das machst du voll gut!
>> FREDERIC: Ich weiß. Ich bin ja auch halber Schwabe.
Ich bin ja auch hier aufgewachsen,
in Neckarsulm. Ja.
>> SALLY: Warum schwätzen wir nicht
das ganze Video über so?
>> FREDERIC: Weil das einfach
nur noch unangenehm ist irgendwann.
Wir müssen auch ein bisschen ein Gesicht wahren,
ein bisschen Nähe haben zum Zuschauer.
>> SALLY: Oh, das ist vorbei!
>> FREDERIC: Ja, das ist vorbei jetzt.
Jetzt haben sie alle abgeschaltet.
>> SALLY: Okay, Rühri.
>> FREDERIC: Yes!
Rühri, da sind wir jetzt dabei geblieben?
>> SALLY: Ja, der heißt Rühri.
>> FREDERIC: Ich hätte dir ein paar Äuglein mitbringen sollen.
>> SALLY: Ja!
>> FREDERIC: Einfach rein und dann?
>> SALLY: Für hier dann so, tick, tick, tick.
Ja.
Und jetzt erst mal verrühren,
bis sich der Puderzucker mit dem Quark verbunden hat.
>> FREDERIC: Langsam dazu einfach?
>> SALLY: Die Sahne langsam dazu.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Die sollte kalt sein.
>> FREDERIC: Aha.
>> SALLY: Schlagsahne immer aus dem Kühlschrank.
>> SALLY: Ich wusste nämlich,
dass du den Fehler wahrscheinlich machst,
>> FREDERIC: Nein, nein, nein!
>> SALLY: dass die immer zimmerwarm ist.
>> FREDERIC: Ach Quatschi! Die ist immer...
Du weißt ja, Rezepte anrichten und Zutaten und so was,
das kann ich immer.
>> SALLY: Keine Bohrmaschine.
Okay.
>> FREDERIC: Ich glaube, das Bild ist fest.
>> SALLY: Ja, das ist fest.
>> FREDERIC: Das ist so.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt pro 100 Gramm...
>> FREDERIC: Schneller?
>> SALLY: Nö. Aber ein bisschen einmal kurz außenrum,
dass... Ja.
Pro 100 Gramm Masse einen Teelöffel
Sahnestand mit rein, also San-apart.
>> FREDERIC: Warum ist da eigentlich nur einer drin?
>> SALLY: Das sind zwei.
Weil das ist ja der Schneebesen
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: und das andere sind die Rührbesen.
>> SALLY: Und bei Rührbesen nimmst du zwei.
Die arbeiten dann so den Teig in die Mitte.
Und der Schneebesen, der hat ja einen großen, voluminösen
Schneebesen.
Drei,
vier,
fünf,
sechs,
sieben,
acht
und neun.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
Hm.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt aufpassen, dass du nicht zu lange rührst.
>> FREDERIC: Und schneller?
>> SALLY: Und aber auch nicht...
Nee, das passt so.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: Kein Turbo-Power-Boost.
>> FREDERIC: Immer alles sehr behutsam, nicht?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: So vorsichtig und so.
>> SALLY: Schön langsam die Luft einschlagen.
Sieht schon gut aus.
Guck mal, wenn sie so ist...
>> FREDERIC: Macht man nicht den Kopftest?
>> SALLY: Nee, das machst du nur einmal mit Sahne.
>> FREDERIC: Ah.
>> SALLY: Dann...
>> FREDERIC: Nicht?
>> SALLY: Nee.
Mit Eischnee kannst du es machen,
aber bei Sahne eher nicht.
Weil die...
>> FREDERIC: Das klappt doch.
>> SALLY: Ja, es klappt, aber die kann rausrutschen.
Soll ich?
Ich übernehme keine Haftung.
>> FREDERIC: Nee, lass mal nicht machen gerade.
Mhm. Nee.
>> SALLY: Weil du siehst,
durch das Fett kann die halt schon gleich so wusch.
>> FREDERIC: Okay. Gut.
>> SALLY: Aber, wenn sie so ist, ist sie perfekt.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Also nicht mehr weiterrühren.
Okay?
Und dann so tschung.
>> FREDERIC: Yes.
>> SALLY: Ich stelle die kurz kalt, räume hier auf.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Dann haben wir Platz für die Naked Torte.
>> FREDERIC: Und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder!
Und jetzt YouTuber-Übergang!
Ach so!
Yo, was geht?
>> SALLY: So.
Wir dekorieren
– also Freddie dekoriert jetzt.
Und wir haben hier einmal den Schokobiskuit.
Ta-daa!
Möchtest du den schneiden?
>> FREDERIC: Klar!
Wie auch immer.
>> SALLY: Zweimal durch.
So mit der Säge tschuk, tschuk, tschuk hier rein.
>> FREDERIC: Ach, echt?
>> SALLY: Ich halte dann immer hier so fest. So.
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und dann...
>> FREDERIC: Aber dann schneidet man sich doch was ab.
>> SALLY: Nein. Weil das ist so ein Draht, der ist nicht scharf.
Genau. Genau.
Und am Ende so mit der Hand so ein bisschen dagegen,
so ein bisschen, ja, so stützen.
Soll ich ein Pflaster holen?
>> FREDERIC: Ah! Ah!
Aah!
Nein.
Ja, okay.
>> SALLY: Nee, das ist ja stumpf deswegen.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Geht gut.
>> FREDERIC: Boah!
>> SALLY: Und dann hier noch mal.
>> FREDERIC: Knuspert das
>> SALLY: Dann haben wir zwei Schichten
>> FREDERIC: im Knäuschen.
>> SALLY: – also drei.
>> FREDERIC: So und dann noch mal einfach durch?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Einfach so?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Nicht verstellen?
>> SALLY: Nö.
>> FREDERIC: Guck so ein bisschen hier.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Weißt du was?
Wir machen eine richtig coole Naked Torte.
Wir nehmen jetzt noch
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: – das ist ja der Schokobiskuit.
Und jetzt nehmen wir noch den hier.
Und dann mischen wir einfach.
>> FREDERIC: Dann wird das ja sehr hoch.
>> SALLY: Ja. Aber so...
>> FREDERIC: Machst du den?
>> SALLY: Aber so Torten...
Nee, mach du. Du kannst das gut.
Aber so Torten sehen cool aus, wenn sie hoch sind.
Damit kann man echt beeindrucken.
Okay. Komm.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Hier ist deine Tortendrehplatte.
>> FREDERIC: Yes.
>> SALLY: Dann
nehmen wir das.
Dann rutscht es nicht.
Und dann nimmst du am besten den Deckel,
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: also einen Tortendeckel,
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: und drehst ihn um.
>> FREDERIC: Aha.
>> SALLY: Denn dann können wir später den Boden,
der ja schön gerade ist, als Abschluss nehmen.
>> FREDERIC: Ah!
>> SALLY: Upside down.
>> FREDERIC: Fies,
die Tricks der Szene!
>> SALLY: Hm.
Und jetzt
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: hier Spritzbeutelständer.
>> FREDERIC: Ja!
Oder auch ein sehr großer Krug.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Dann nehmen wir eine Spritztülle, so eine runde.
>> FREDERIC: Dass du das so groß schneiden kannst,
dass das perfekt da raus passt,
ist Wahnsinn für mich!
Das sind so kleine Sachen.
Hui!
>> SALLY: Und dann schlägst du das hier so um,
dass es nicht rausläuft.
>> FREDERIC: Klar.
>> SALLY: Und hier oben rein.
>> FREDERIC: Da haben mir die Leute gesagt,
als ich das so faszinierend fand, haben die gesagt:
"Geht auch mit einem Weizenglas."
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Falls man das nicht hat.
>> SALLY: Das geht auch.
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
Machen die Leute Freestyle damit zu Hause,
>> SALLY: Ha ja, natürlich!
>> FREDERIC: weil sie noch keinen Sally-Krug haben.
>> SALLY: So.
Und jetzt da rein.
Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Ach so! Das da rein?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Ach so, okay.
Ja, wusste ich natürlich genau, dass das gemeint ist.
So.
Und dann einfach rein?
>> SALLY: Guck mal, was für eine perfekte Sahne
du gemacht hast!
Mein Gott!
>> FREDERIC: Ja, du, das ist natürlich auch
– wer mich kennt, weiß, zwei Sachen sind es.
Es ist Sahne...
>> SALLY: Das ist der Hammer!
>> FREDERIC: Es ist Sahne und es ist Pizza.
Das sind meine beiden Tops.
>> SALLY: Woah!
Ja.
>> FREDERIC: 10 von 10?
>> SALLY: Komm, das reicht.
>> FREDERIC: Oder mehr?
>> SALLY: Nee, das passt.
>> FREDERIC: Für den Geschmack noch.
>> SALLY: Ja, komm, für den Geschmack.
>> FREDERIC: Und eins dann noch mal.
>> SALLY: Ja, eins noch. So.
>> FREDERIC: Für den Uwe.
>> SALLY: Das auch noch.
>> FREDERIC: Für den Corgi hier.
>> SALLY: Ta-ta-ta-ta-taa.
>> FREDERIC: Für die...
Für die Silke.
Eins noch für alle.
>> SALLY: Und eins für Murat.
>> FREDERIC: Und eins für den Muri.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Voll schön!
>> FREDERIC: Mag der das, wenn man den so nennt?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Der Muri?
>> SALLY: Bestimmt.
>> FREDERIC: Spitznamen by Freddie.
So.
>> FREDERIC: So rauf, rüber
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: und dann hoch?
>> FREDERIC: Also hoch?
>> SALLY: Ja, hoch.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: Sehr gut.
Und dann oben zudrehen.
>> FREDERIC: So?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Sehr gut.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und dann so leicht runterdrücken.
Genau.
Und dann hat man eine Hand oben,
die drückt,
also die übt den Druck aus,
und die andere unten, die führt.
Okay?
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt spritzt du hier außenrum so einen Ring.
>> FREDERIC: Am Stück?
>> SALLY: Am Stück oder abgesetzt.
>> FREDERIC: Puh!
Okay.
Heute ist echt – hui!
Und dann drehe ich das so?
>> SALLY: Und dann am besten so halten.
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
Und dann drehe ich das so dabei oder du?
>> SALLY: Ich drehe es. Komm.
Ich mache wie bei
– wie beim Töpfern.
Huch! Sorry!
>> FREDERIC: Was war das denn gerade?
Jetzt hast du aber ein bisschen Quatschi gemacht.
>> SALLY: War zu schnell.
>> FREDERIC: So.
Okay.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Siehst du?
>> FREDERIC: Sagen wir mal, bis auf
den Fehler, den du jetzt eingebaut hast...
>> SALLY: Den ich gemacht habe.
>> FREDERIC: War wirklich fantastisch bis dahin!
>> SALLY: War super!
>> FREDERIC: Und dann den Rest davon da rein?
>> SALLY: Und dann kommt hier die Füllung rein.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
Boah! Das sieht Hammer aus!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Ich finde das gut!
Ist das dann unser Rezept?
>> SALLY: Das ist dann unser Rezept.
>> FREDERIC: Yay! Ich habe ein Rezept jetzt!
>> SALLY: Ja, ich schreibe rein: Freddies No-Bake
– nicht No-Bake.
>> FREDERIC: No-Bake...
>> SALLY: Naked!
>> FREDERIC: No baked potato.
>> SALLY: Naked...
>> FREDERIC: Und dann einfach ein Bild von einer Kartoffel.
Zehn Minuten in Wasser
und gucken, was passiert, Leute.
>> SALLY: So.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt aber...
Guck mal. Dreh oben noch mal nach. Weil ich sehe schon,
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: dass da ein bisschen so der Druck nachlässt.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ja, genau.
>> SALLY: Und immer aufpassen, dass du mit den Händen
die Creme da drin nicht so warm machst.
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: Weil dann schmilzt die ja.
>> FREDERIC: Ich habe sehr warme Hände. Ja, okay.
Also, und dann...
>> SALLY: Wieder aufrecht. Tschu.
>> FREDERIC: Yes. Und dann drehst du wieder,
machen wir Teamwork
>> SALLY: Ja, okay.
>> FREDERIC: und dann mache ich wieder,
ja, so.
Bis dato noch okay dabei, würdest du sagen, oder?
>> SALLY: Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Und zack!
>> FREDERIC: O Gott!
O Gott!
>> SALLY: Das ist gerade wie bei Mario Kart so Spurwechsel.
Tschu
und zack!
>> FREDERIC: Ach du Heiliger!
O Gott!
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich hier genau drücke,
aber irgendwas kommt noch weiter raus.
Es wird unangenehm,
weil ich bin echt bei meinem Handgelenk angekommen!
Oh nein!
Ojemine!
Okay. Ja, alles gut. Habe ich gemacht.
>> SALLY: Ich wollte nur einmal schneller drehen.
Ja. Und dann kannst du es auch immer wieder hier abstellen.
>> FREDERIC: Manchmal
bist du ein ganz schöner Quatschkopf. Weißt du das?
>> SALLY: Was?! Ich?!
>> FREDERIC: Ja, du bist ein Quatschkopf manchmal.
>> SALLY: Ich doch nicht!
>> FREDERIC: Du bist manchmal ein Frechdachs.
Sagt man, nicht?
Frechdachs.
>> SALLY: Vielleicht.
>> FREDERIC: Vielleicht!
>> SALLY: Und jetzt hier
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: so glatt streichen.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ich bin nur manchmal frech.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, aber das ist auch okay.
Muss man auch sein.
>> SALLY: Ja, muss man auch sein.
>> FREDERIC: Sonst geht es hier nicht weiter.
>> SALLY: So. Guck!
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Schön!
>> FREDERIC: 400 Prozent!
>> SALLY: Und jetzt können wir ja
so einen dunklen Boden nehmen,
so den aus der Mitte zum Beispiel.
>> FREDERIC: Einfach drauf setzen?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
>> SALLY: Und wenn man es
– eigentlich muss man Schwarzwälder Kirschtorte
mit Kirschwasser machen.
Dann muss man so die Böden tränken
und die Creme noch mit Kirschwasser und so.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, jetzt schwierig.
Aber so ist es cooler.
Ich empfehle dieses Rezept.
>> SALLY: Ich finde es auch cool.
Ja, ja.
>> FREDERIC: Okay, kriege ich hin.
>> SALLY: Also noch mal.
[Musik]
Aber eigentlich sehen so Naked Cakes schon gut aus,
wenn die wirklich so schön hoch sind.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
Also schon vier Etagen?
>> SALLY: Dann ist es schon so eine Angebertorte.
>> FREDERIC: Zählt das dann als Hochzeitstorte,
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: wenn ich so zwei Kerzen da drauf stelle?
Dann gibst du mir noch ein Feuerzeug mit oder so...
Und dann...
>> SALLY: Sollen wir sie Hochzeitstorte nennen?
>> FREDERIC: Und dann...
>> SALLY: Ich habe sogar so einen Wedding Topper.
>> FREDERIC: Vielleicht nicht.
Nee.
>> SALLY: Hä?
Ist ja nicht unsere.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, ja, passt schon.
So.
>> SALLY: Okay. Komm, weiter.
>> FREDERIC: Murat, bitte!
Ich gehe hier bald raus so:
"Ja, es war ein toller Besuch.
Es war ein megatoller Besuch bei Sally so."
Ja, okay.
So.
Uff!
Ja.
>> SALLY: Und aufrecht.
>> FREDERIC: Hm. Ja, gerne.
O Gott! O Gott!
Was passiert hier gerade?!
O Gott! Das sieht aus wie mein Lebenslauf, ey,
immer wieder mit Unterbrechungen
und einfach nur großen Problemen hier.
Ojemine!
Oh, was ist denn mit dir los hier?
O Gott!
Ja, ja.
In der Mitte wird es immer schwierig, nicht?
Da ist ein kleiner Turm jetzt.
>> SALLY: Wow!
>> FREDERIC: Seien wir mal ganz ehrlich.
Muss man das wirklich mit so einem Spritzi machen,
wenn man es eh glatt streicht?
Das ist schon einfach nur noch...
>> SALLY: Ja, eigentlich ist er dafür da,
dass wirklich die Creme gleichmäßig dann...
>> FREDERIC: Ist doch voll gleichmäßig!
Siehst du das Stück da links,
den Balkon, den ich eingebaut habe?
Da kannst du schön auf die Terrasse mal,
irgendwie schön über – wuh! – die Welt gucken und so.
Ja. Okay.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Okay, okay.
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: Es entstehen gerade so viele neue Videoideen
bei mir im Kopf.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, es ist schlimm,
wenn man mit mir unterwegs ist, nicht?
>> SALLY: Das sind so, wow, basic...
>> FREDERIC: Du glaubst gar nicht,
wie viele YouTube-Karrieren ich hinter der Szene
aufgebaut habe mit meinen Ideen immer!
>> SALLY: Wie halte ich einen Spritzbeutel?
Wie halte ich den richtig?
>> FREDERIC: Lass mich doch einfach mal
eine Basic-Serie auf der Sally-Webseite machen!
Hi Leute!
Wenn ihr mal keine Ahnung habt,
aber auch weiterkommen wollt im Leben.
>> SALLY: O Mann, ey!
>> FREDERIC: Ich habe ja früher mal
ein Praktikum in der Küche gemacht.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Und danach habe ich mir eine Sache
geschworen,
nie irgendwas in meinem Leben mit Kochen zu machen.
Guckst du mal, was mein Wort wert ist zu mir selber.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: So.
Ich probiere das jetzt mal so.
[Musik]
Du machst das extra schneller, nicht?
>> SALLY: Nein!
>> FREDERIC: Du machst das.
Guck mal! Da ist schon zweimal unterbrochen gewesen.
O mein Gott! Ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich tue!
Ah, Senftube! Senftube!
So. Okay.
Das ist zweimal an der gleichen Stelle!
Wie ist das denn passiert?
>> SALLY: Schön!
Und du darfst jetzt noch den Tortendeckel drauf setzen.
Den hier.
>> FREDERIC: Geil!
>> SALLY: Und aber upside down.
Genau. Das schön umdrehen.
>> FREDERIC: Umdrehen. Einmal klappen. Okay.
Upside down?
So?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Oh!
>> FREDERIC: Wow!
>> SALLY: Ist das schön!
>> FREDERIC: Das sieht wirklich sehr gut aus!
>> SALLY: Das sieht richtig gut aus!
>> FREDERIC: Und auch schon wieder so groß,
muss man einfach mal sagen, wenn man so nah davor steht,
dass das wirklich niemand direkt
mit einem Bissen in den Mund kriegen könnte.
Wenn, dann macht er das nur einmal.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Aber ist doch gut, nicht?
>> SALLY: Das ist echt gut.
>> FREDERIC: Was hast du da?
>> MURAT: Hey, das ist ein Monk. Pass du auf, ey!
>> FREDERIC: Ist das dein Ernst gerade?
>> SALLY: Sie ist gerade.
Warte.
>> FREDERIC: Wir schneiden den jetzt an.
Nein.
Das ist schon...
Sag mal.
Du bist doch Schwabe.
>> SALLY: So ist es gut!
>> FREDERIC: Ist das normal?
>> MURAT: Ja.
Wahnsinn, oder?
>> SALLY: Ist doch jetzt gerade.
>> MURAT: Ich sage doch, das ist...
Freddie, das ist der Monk!
Das ist der Monk.
>> SALLY: Ich?!
>> MURAT: Weißt du, wie wir Männer das machen würden?
>> FREDERIC: Säge?
>> MURAT: Ja.
Wir würden den wahrscheinlich kaufen.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Entschuldigung?!
So.
Und das ist jetzt schon mal ein guter Naked Cake.
>> FREDERIC: Nee!
Nee!
>> SALLY: Doch.
>> FREDERIC: Nee!
>> SALLY: Soll ich dir eine mitgeben?
Oh!
>> FREDERIC: Was?!
Das ist...
Nee! Das ist doch nicht dafür da!
>> SALLY: Soll ich dir eine mitgeben?
>> FREDERIC: Aber warum denn?
Das macht doch keiner!
Also sorry.
>> SALLY: Doch!
>> FREDERIC: Alles andere hier, geil!
Ich atme gerne die Luft, wo Sally draufsteht auf dem,
wenn du ganz nah ranzoomst,
aber das hier,
da muss ich einschreiten.
Da bin ich raus.
Nee!
>> SALLY: Keiner mag schiefe Torten!
>> FREDERIC: Doch, die in Pisa!
Piu!
Jetzt probier noch mal zurückzukommen, hä?
>> MURAT: Oh!
>> FREDERIC: Ist gerade.
Das hast du voll gut gemacht. Sorry.
>> SALLY: Also ich würde sagen,
wir nehmen einfach Restcreme
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: immer hier so dran.
>> FREDERIC: Und das wird dann so gestrichen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Aber man soll die Böden schon noch durchsehen.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
Ja, dass das immer so
>> SALLY: Das ist ja so bei...
>> FREDERIC: imperfekt perfekt aussieht.
>> SALLY: Genau.
>> FREDERIC: Wann ist dieses Naked-Cake-Ding
eigentlich gewesen?
Das war ja schon ein bisschen her, – nicht? –
als das so hochgekocht ist.
Weil ich habe da mal
>> SALLY: Ja. Ich...
Rezepte gefunden vor ein paar Jährchen so.
>> SALLY: Aber es muss halt schon
auf der einen Seite perfekt sein,
perfekt imperfekt.
>> FREDERIC: Was ist das jetzt für ein Gerät?
>> SALLY: Die Teigkarte.
Damit kannst du einstreichen
und Teig schneiden.
>> FREDERIC: Sagen wir mal,
es würde jetzt hart auf hart kommen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Loch in einer Wand.
Spachtelmasse.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Es muss dringend...
>> SALLY: Ja!
>> FREDERIC: Es ist schon einfach nur ein längerer Spachtel.
>> SALLY: Ja, dann nimmst du das.
>> FREDERIC: Okay, habe ich verstanden.
Hier muss ich wieder sagen,
>> SALLY: Guck, hier!
>> FREDERIC: bin ich voll an Bord.
Weil das hat einen Multifunktionsaspekt für mich.
>> SALLY: Na klar!
Und dann hier.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt nur noch ein bisschen die Oberfläche?
Magst du?
[Musik]
Ja, so rum. Genau.
Weil dann siehst du, wo die Creme hingeht,
und dann weißt du, wo du hindrücken musst.
>> FREDERIC: Aha.
Guckst du mal?
Ging wohl doch nicht so wie bei jedem normalen Menschen,
aber selbst ich kriege eine glatte Oberfläche hin,
auch wenn es nur zehn Minuten länger dauert als bei euch.
Aber kein Problem.
Auch Menschen können sich
in diesem Format hier durchsetzen.
Ah!
>> SALLY: Also, und dann...
>> FREDERIC: Soll ich noch ein Muster reinmachen?
>> SALLY: Ja, kannst du?
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
Ich kann gute Muster.
Das ist bis dato mein Spezialgebiet.
>> SALLY: Mach mal.
>> FREDERIC: Jetzt machst du Kreis und ich bin X.
Oh!
Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich war.
Hier.
>> FREDERIC: Nein! Das war doch meins.
Ja, gut. Okay.
Wir nennen es "Die
Torte".
>> SALLY: Die Tic-Tac-Toe-Torte.
>> FREDERIC: Die Tic-Tac-Schwarzwälder-Kirsch-
>> SALLY: Okay, komm.
>> FREDERIC: Toe.
>> SALLY: Komm, wir machen noch kurz glatt und dann
– ich zeige dir jetzt den Trick dann gleich.
Dann ist das...
>> FREDERIC: Ich mache weg hier.
>> SALLY: Ja. Dann ist das Ding hier
die perfekte Torte.
Wir müssen sie nur kurz kühlen.
Weil hier drin hat es wieder 80°C.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich merke schon, ich...
Puh!
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: So.
>> SALLY: Ja? Gefällt es dir?
>> FREDERIC: Yes. Perfekt! Sieht super aus!
>> SALLY: So, Naked. Zack, zack.
Und dann
überlege ich mir, während wir hier aufräumen,
wie wir sie weiter dekorieren.
Denn ich habe mir noch keine
– ich habe mir noch nichts überlegt.
>> FREDERIC: Das heißt, wir sehen uns gleich wieder.
>> SALLY: Stimmt.
O Mann!
Ich bin echt schlecht mit den Übergängen.
>> FREDERIC: Ah! So macht man das?
>> SALLY: Ja. Guck mal. So drunter und dann so.
>> FREDERIC: Ich habe halt nur von dir
zwei von diesen ganz Langen, die so gluck, gluck machen.
Weißt du, was ich meine?
>> SALLY: Oh! Habe ich dir die Größe nicht geschickt?
>> FREDERIC: Nee, nee.
>> SALLY: Die mittlere Größe?
>> FREDERIC: Und das mit den anderen
ist halt viel, viel challenger
– challengemäßiger.
>> SALLY: Ja, weil die anderen sind halt länger
und dann hast du mehr so – tschung –
>> FREDERIC: Ja, ja. Das ist aber gut.
>> SALLY: so Federn.
>> FREDERIC: Ja, ein Tschung.
>> SALLY: Du kannst so...
>> FREDERIC: So und dann jetzt
>> SALLY: Okay. Und jetzt, dachte ich...
>> FREDERIC: reißen wir die Stiele von der Schokolade ab
und ich schäle dann nach und nach die Kirschen
auf den Kuchen drauf.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Achtung. Du kannst jetzt nämlich
>> FREDERIC: Was denn?
>> SALLY: Schokoröllchen machen.
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: Der Josh, der kriegt sich gleich nicht mehr
hinter der Kamera.
Dann so.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
Boah, das ist ja megaschwierig!
>> SALLY: Warte mal. Ich zeige es dir mal mit dem.
>> FREDERIC: Ach so. Ja, klar.
>> SALLY: Weil der ist echt einfacher.
Weil da kannst du so ansetzen – guck –
>> FREDERIC: Boah!
>> SALLY: und so krasse Röllchen machen.
>> FREDERIC: Aber sind wir mal ganz ehrlich.
Das ist ja schon eine Arbeit, die man sich damit macht, nicht?
Und kommt dann...
>> SALLY: Da kannst du tschu, tschu,
>> FREDERIC: Ja, beide Seiten, nicht? Das ist...
>> SALLY: tschu, tschu.
Ja.
>> FREDERIC: So ein Kuchen ist ein Projekt, Leute.
Selbst, wenn der Boden fertig ist, es dauert Stunden!
>> SALLY: Aber... Ach, komm!
Wir haben viel Quatsch gemacht!
>> FREDERIC: Es ist doch super!
Ich sage doch gar nichts dagegen.
>> SALLY: Guck. Und dann so tschu.
>> FREDERIC: Ich sage nur:
Nehmt euch vier bis acht Stunden Zeit.
>> SALLY: Aber das sieht doch voll cool aus!
>> FREDERIC: Aber kam dann schon mal jemand auf dich zu
und hat gesagt: "Boah, diese Schokoröllchen da unten,
die du da drangemacht hast bei so einem Projekt,
das ist schon das Geilste,
weil du dir damit richtig Mühe gegeben hast"?
>> SALLY: Ja, jedes Mal.
Du sollst nicht lügen, nicht?
Okay. Nein, es hat noch keiner gesagt,
meine Schokoröllchen sind schön.
Könnt ihr das bitte kommentieren?
>> FREDERIC: Das hast du jetzt so als weirden Insider
und dann ist es auch komisch,
wenn es so kontextuell nicht mehr passt, nicht?
Stell dir mal vor, du bist auf einer Messe,
dann stehen Leute an und jemand sagt:
"Deine Schokoröllchen sind schön."
Das ist ja auch vielleicht ein komischer Moment so.
>> SALLY: Und ich so:
>> FREDERIC: "Äh,
>> SALLY: "Die?
>> FREDERIC: was habe ich denn jetzt
>> SALLY: Oder die?"
>> FREDERIC: wieder gemacht?"
So.
>> SALLY: Also, wenn du dann diese Schokoröllchen hast,
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich habe halt echt immer so
warme Hände.
Dann mache ich das halt so, dass die nicht schmelzen.
Und dann können die vielleicht da unten so dran.
Hm?
>> FREDERIC: Randrücken?
>> SALLY: Sieht doch cool aus, oder?
>> FREDERIC: Und wie sieht das mit den Kirschen aus?
Die einfach nur...
>> SALLY: Die machen wir obendrauf so.
>> FREDERIC: Mit den Stielen?
>> SALLY: Ja! Voll wild.
Immer das hier...
>> FREDERIC: Ich finde so simple Sachen eigentlich ganz gut,
muss ich sagen.
>> SALLY: Oh! Aus welcher Werbung?
Da war es doch so.
Ah, mit der Piemont-Kirsche.
>> FREDERIC: Mit der Piemont-Kirsche, wo einfach
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: wir wieder nicht wissen:
Woher kommt die Piemont-Kirsche?
Wir sehen uns sofort wieder bei einem Wikipedia-Exkurs.
>> SALLY: Aha! "Die große Lüge um die 'Piemont-Kirsche'"
>> FREDERIC: Jetzt bin ich gespannt, du.
>> SALLY: Ah!
"Das Wort Piemont-Kirsche ist...
Eine Kirschsorte dieses Namens existiert nicht."
>> FREDERIC: Heute was gelernt über Kirschen
und einen großen Kirschenskandal aufgedeckt.
>> SALLY: Ein richtiger Kirschenskandal!
>> FREDERIC: Von daher, schaltet öfter ein, wenn es heißt:
Detektivin Sally
d-d-d-da!
>> SALLY: Sally Bollywood, sie hat eine eigene Detektei!
>> FREDERIC: Ach du heilige Mutter, ey!
>> SALLY: Naa-naa-na-na-na-na-naa!
Naa-naa-na-na-na-na-naa!
>> FREDERIC: Jetzt kommt bald die Synchrolle bei Paw Patrol.
>> SALLY: Und sie hat einen
Dann sind wir richtig hier durch.
>> SALLY: Detektivassistent.
Er heißt Sturmi.
Naa-naa-na-na-na-na-naa!
>> FREDERIC: Nickelodeon, einfach anrufen.
Assent-/gagemäßig,
wir müssen einfach nur kurz reden.
Animateure haben wir bestimmt noch hier oben sitzen
bei den ganzen Mitarbeitern und dann geht es richtig los.
>> SALLY: Ja, der Marcel, der animiert da was.
[Musik]
>> FREDERIC: Und er so: "Ach, kurz!
Was denken die immer alle, dass das so schnell geht?
Ah!"
>> SALLY: Weißt du, bei Naked Cake
das sieht ja immer so zufällig aus,
so: "Woah, zufällig die Torte so schön gemacht."
Und dabei war es dann alles...
Nicht bis an den Rand.
Genau, so mehr in der Mitte.
Guck, von unten so nach oben streichen.
>> FREDERIC: Hm, hm.
>> SALLY: Das sieht schon cool aus.
>> FREDERIC: Was sagst du hierzu?
>> SALLY: Ja, mega!
Ich würde nur noch ein paar mehr dazu packen.
>> FREDERIC: Echt?
>> SALLY: So. Weißt du, so.
>> FREDERIC: So da drüber?
>> SALLY: So tschu, tschu.
>> FREDERIC: Jetzt habe ich mir so Mühe gegeben.
>> SALLY: So nachbauen.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Wie auf so einer türkischen Hochzeit.
>> FREDERIC: So ist eine türkische Hochzeit?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> FREDERIC: Seid ihr Kirschchen?
>> SALLY: Das ist so die Tanzfläche.
>> FREDERIC: Das ist die Tanzfläche?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Tja.
>> SALLY: Oh! Apropos Hochzeit!
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Achtung.
Ich habe was vorbereitet.
>> FREDERIC: Back to the nature?
>> SALLY: Ja, so...
Keine Ahnung.
>> FREDERIC: Back to the nature?
Was steht da jetzt drauf?
Mayo?
>> SALLY: Der Sturmi hat eine Hochzeitstorte gebacken.
>> FREDERIC: Ah!
Mr & Mrs!
Ich dachte, da steht Mayonnaise für Mayo oder so was.
Das ist eine Mayonnaise-Torte!
>> SALLY: Oh, komm!
Das ist doch voll die coole Hochzeitstorte!
>> FREDERIC: Das ist richtig schön!
Ich würde sagen, das hier ist definitiv die schönste Torte,
neben der ich jemals stand.
>> SALLY: Und vor allem mit diesem Holzstecker!
Das ist dann so
Natur und so Holz
und Schwarzwald
und Kirschtorte.
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und hey, innerhalb von wenigen Minuten
habt ihr die perfekte No-Bake-
– nicht No-Bake, Naked –
Naked Cake.
>> FREDERIC: No cake, it's a potato cake.
>> SALLY: No cake. Ja.
Oder?
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
Die Naked
– almost naked.
>> SALLY: Almost naked.
>> FREDERIC: It's a bikini...
It's a bikini...
>> SALLY: Ja!
>> FREDERIC: It's a bikini
>> SALLY: It's a Bikini-Torte.
>> FREDERIC: – Bikini-Schwarzwälder-Kirsch.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und ich muss sagen, du hast dich echt gut angestellt.
>> FREDERIC: Oder du hast mir ja auch zum Glück
kaum geholfen.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich habe nicht geholfen.
Ich habe nur moderiert.
>> FREDERIC: Und...
>> SALLY: Yay!
>> DANIEL: Ja!
>> SALLY: Da sind wir wieder.
Okay.
Und jetzt testen
die zwei Schwaben
und die eine Badenerin
– großer Unterschied –
die Torte.
>> FREDERIC: Worin liegt der Unterschied genau?
>> DANIEL: Ja?
>> SALLY: Dass die Badener besser sind?
>> DANIEL: In was?
>> SALLY: Im Backen.
>> DANIEL: Stuttgart ist aufgestiegen.
Und der KSC ist
in der 2. Liga.
>> SALLY: Wir reden auf meinem Kanal nicht über Fußball,
nicht über Politik und nicht über Religion.
>> FREDERIC: Das finde ich sehr gut.
Borussia Mönchengladbach.
Champions League nach wie vor können wir.
So.
Grüßen gehen raus.
>> SALLY: Und dann, dann, dann, dann...
>> FREDERIC: Wie bescheiden sie tut!
>> SALLY: Wuh!
>> FREDERIC: Oh, das ist bei mir genauso.
Zum Glück, ey, selbst...
>> SALLY: Das sind jetzt die Kirschen hier.
Und dann musst du so machen.
So.
>> FREDERIC: Okay.
Ich lasse die immer fallen
für den Splash-Effekt.
>> SALLY: Ah!
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Aber so sieht es aus wie ein Profi.
Guck. Und dann noch so.
>> FREDERIC: Boah!
Geil!
Und jetzt Haarspray und dann Bild, Leute! Los geht's!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Ah, wirklich?
>> DANIEL: Ja, das ist der Glitzer.
>> FREDERIC: Geil!
>> SALLY: Der Glanz für die Kirschen.
Jetzt haben wir ihn.
>> FREDERIC: Geil!
>> DANIEL: Okay.
Ladies first.
>> FREDERIC: Danke schön. Yes. Yes.
>> SALLY: Jetzt müssten wir eigentlich so...
Och!
>> FREDERIC: Sind wir noch gemein hier?
>> SALLY: So.
Weißt du? So wie bei der Hochzeit.
So da, da.
Hier, Schatz.
Das könnt ihr...
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> FREDERIC: Das könnt ihr intern austragen.
Da will ich nichts mit zu tun haben hier.
Danke, Schatz.
So.
>> SALLY: Ja, ihr zwei macht das.
>> FREDERIC: So.
>> DANIEL: Ah, du hast Ahnung!
Oben weg.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> FREDERIC: Richtig.
>> DANIEL: Ha!
>> FREDERIC: So schön drauf kommt immer gut.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> DANIEL: Wie lang habt ihr jetzt gebraucht?
>> SALLY: Nur eine Stunde.
>> FREDERIC: Ein Viertelstündchen.
>> SALLY: Ein Viertelstündchen.
>> FREDERIC: Wenn es zusammengeschnitten ist,
an die acht Minuten.
Ab dann kamen wir mit Rolls.
Alles gut.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Mit Kühlzeit und so schon so
vier Stunden.
>> FREDERIC: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber geht.
>> FREDERIC: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Hm?
>> DANIEL: Boah!
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ist schon nicht schlecht, nicht?
>> FREDERIC: Da guckst du mal an, Schwarzwälder Kirsch,
habe ich heute noch mal die Leute glücklich gemacht hier.
>> DANIEL: Boah!
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
Boah, geil!
Das ist neu, neue und geile Schwarzwälder Kirsch.
>> SALLY: Oder?
>> FREDERIC: 10 von 10.
>> SALLY: Ich finde auch,
>> FREDERIC: 10 von 10 Kirschen, Sally.
>> SALLY: so die traditionelle ist einfach...
>> DANIEL: Geiler Biss.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> DANIEL: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und die zwei Biskuitfarben finde ich auch cool.
>> FREDERIC: Wären die dir aufgefallen,
die zwei Biskuitfarben?
>> DANIEL: Hm, klar.
Wollte ich gerade noch ansprechen.
>> FREDERIC: Hm.
>> DANIEL: Also
>> SALLY: Ach, komm!
>> DANIEL: das habt ihr mir jetzt vorweggenommen, aber...
>> FREDERIC: Ja, ist das...
>> SALLY: Das fällt schon auf.
>> DANIEL: Natürlich!
>> FREDERIC: Boah! Dieses
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> FREDERIC: diese Joghurt-Pudding-Creme, nicht?
>> DANIEL: Also ich bin jetzt als Zweites,
zum zweiten Mal als Tester hier
und muss sagen...
>> SALLY: Erst. Ja.
>> DANIEL: Ja, erst.
>> SALLY: Und?
>> DANIEL: Aber ich muss sagen...
>> SALLY: Wie ist es hier im Badener Land?
>> DANIEL: Ja...
>> FREDERIC: Das ist Baden hier?
>> DANIEL: Ich wollte gerade sagen, also
>> FREDERIC: Das erklärt einiges.
>> DANIEL: ich war öfters als zweimal im Badener Land,
aber
>> SALLY: Das schönste Land!
>> DANIEL: mega! Wirklich!
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> DANIEL: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Megalecker! Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> FREDERIC: Also es sind von mir
nach wie vor 10 von 10 Kirschen, Sally.
>> SALLY: Ja!
Ja!
10 von 10 Törtchen!
>> DANIEL: 9,9 von 10 von mir.
>> SALLY: Wegen?
Badenerabzug?
>> DANIEL: Nee, den Gnocchi-Salat.
>> FREDERIC: Nee, er ist sehr kartoffelig.
Weil die Kartoffel gibt nie 10 von 10, wenn was richtig gut ist.
Die sagt immer: "Es war das Beste, was ich jemals hatte.
9 von 10."
>> SALLY: Der Daniel will jetzt hören...
>> FREDERIC: Weil die Möglichkeit,
etwas Besseres zu bekommen, sollte immer da sein.
>> DANIEL: Was will er hören?
Sag es.
>> SALLY: Er macht den weltbesten Gnocchi-Salat.
>> DANIEL: 10 von 10 Punkte
für diese Schwarzwälder Kirschtorte.
So.
>> SALLY: Mega! Und ihr seht,
>> FREDERIC: Vielen Dank, dass ich mitmachen durfte!
>> SALLY: ganz einfach. Naked Cake, einfach, modern.
Und ihr habt die perfekte
Hochzeitstorte.
>> FREDERIC: Und falls ihr zu Hause heiraten wollt
vielleicht noch mal,
falls noch mal die Quarantäne kommen sollte oder so,
dann könnt ihr jetzt zuschlagen,
zu Hause schön einen Antrag machen.
Wenn ihr das macht, dann markiert uns beide mal
auf Instagram auf dem Bild, wo ihr das gemacht habt.
>> SALLY: Ja! Wir sind dann eure Trauzeugen.
>> FREDERIC: Und dann machen wir digital
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: machen wir die Trauzeugen für euch.
>> SALLY: Ja,
machen wir.
>> FREDERIC: Definitiv sind wir dabei!
>> SALLY: Also backt die Torte unbedingt nach!
Und wir gönnen uns jetzt gleich noch ein Stückchen und dann...
>> FREDERIC: Auf jeden Fall!
>> SALLY: So. Gehen wir was essen?
Und dann weiter Torte naschen.
>> FREDERIC: Gerne!
Boah! Richtig Lust!
Torti!
>> SALLY: Rühri!
>> FREDERIC: Rühri!
[Musik]